[Music]
over a year later Grand Theft Auto 5
remains one of the most consistently
entertaining video games I've ever
played
not to mention one of the most
convincing it takes on a shinier and
sharper 1080p form in its new home on
the PlayStation 4 but while it's visual
refinements are the most immediately
noticeable upgrade they're not the most
important partly that's because GTA 5 on
the Xbox 360 and PlayStation 3 looked
fantastic anyway even if the crisper
visuals here verge on the incredible at
times partly it's because there are a
host of new additions like vehicles guns
and songs but mostly it's because GTA 5
is almost an entirely different game or
it can be if you choose to play it a
certain way the new first-person mode
fundamentally changes not only how you
view GTA 5 world but your own mentality
towards it 4 while GTA has always been
violent sometimes shockingly so there's
always been something of a disconnect
between that violence and those playing
the game first-person mode removes much
of that disconnect so when I'm
mercilessly slaughtering police officers
in a high score bad or going on a
rampage with an RPG in downtown Los
Santos well I feel an easy yes there are
plenty of first-person shooters around
but few create as convincing a
modern-day setting as GTA does
first-person mode has the power to make
you stop and think about your actions
which is no bad thing in a game that's
long been criticized for glorifying a
life of crime rather than questioning it
the first person perspective feels very
different to that of your typical
shooter - it's slower and more measured
and well more lifelike the gentle head
bobs and animations as you leap over
walls or get carjacked on the highway
are all expertly done and really do draw
you into the game in a way that third
person mode never could the field of
view is also noticeably different with a
very cinematic wide-angle feel that
makes use of some nifty depth of field
effects if you play the excellent PT on
the PlayStation 4 you'll have a good
idea of what to expect here what
first-person is great for shooting and
for exploring a city that looks and
feels so much larger because of it
driving
work so well the twitchy hypersensitive
controls that work well in third person
for pulling off outrageous driving
stunts are just far too sensitive to get
the job done in first person I had to
drop the controller sensitivity down a
few notches just to keep cars on the
road trying to catch Michael son as he
dangles off a boat on the highway for
performing speeding drive-bys are very
difficult missions in the first person
which is arguably more realistic but I
found myself switching back to the third
person in order to get them done
thankfully it's not an either/or
situation and the game remembers your
preference on foot and in vehicles so
you don't have to manually switch
between the two even if you choose to
ignore first person completely GTA 5 has
lost little of its luster since release
this is a series that has consistently
been the most convincing and the most
cinematic in games even now I'm
surprised by just how much GTA nails it
the voice acting the scripting and the
dialogue are simply on another level
this helped create some credible if
wholly unlikable characters - but
perhaps that's the point there may be a
few times you sympathize with retired
gangster Michael as his family life
crumbles around him or when you believe
that wannabe gangster Franklin might be
a nice guy just because he says he's
always trying to do the right thing or
when Trevor
well maybe not travel but these are guys
that are not meant to be liked their
narcissistic psychopathic killers you
don't blink an eyelid at killing
hundreds when it serves their own means
they're not without fault - and there
are moments when a character will
contradict his own motivations seemingly
just to fit a mission structure but the
fact that these characters can be so
convincingly terrifying is a testament
to the great writing on show in GTA 5
that extends to the world at large - the
sprawling gorgeously animated metropolis
of Los Santos deftly satirizes its
real-world inspiration and of America as
a whole sure it's sometimes heavy-handed
but there are few games that would dare
go as far as GTA ders with his
commentary on governments media and
celebrities and fewer still that do it
with such conviction running through it
all are incredible bombastic missions
that play out like Hollywood
blockbusters and the finest of gangster
films heist remain the highlight and the
whole process of planning them out
hiring members of the team
gathering equipment and then hoping that
the fuzz doesn't interfere with them on
the big day is incredibly engrossing
bombs are exploded helicopters are
smashed into the side of skyscrapers an
entire squads of police give chase as
you attempt an escape down the highway
that's not to mention all the random
creeps of los santos who give you side
missions the multiple leisure activities
you can indulge in or the real estate
you can invest in and the stocks you can
buy in the markets you can manipulate or
you can just slack that all off
completely and use Los Santos as your
own wonderful digital playground
indeed it's the adventures that you
create yourself that often prove to be
the most fun
and then there's GTA online it's safe to
say GTA online can get off to a very
good start with server issues and all
manner of balance problems with the
all-new GTA 5 online gets a few boosts
including an enhanced character creator
as well as support for up to 30
simultaneous players
these are nice additions but the mode
still suffers from a lack of direction
at the start although you can import
your old one I opted to create a new
character after which I was dumped into
a sidewalk in Los Santos with little
idea of what I should do next once you
figure out the process of finding jobs
to do like stealing packages from NPCs
or taking part in street races and
people to do them with value or trusty
mobile phone things get more interesting
much has been said about how GTA online
is to open and how easy it is to be
killed by others but for me that's
always been part of its draw trolling
people who've taken themselves far too
seriously in a street race by creating
an epic roadblock still manages to raise
a smile suffice to say if you are hoping
for an epic reinvention of online you
won't find it here but even if online
wasn't part of the GTA 5 package it
wouldn't matter aside from a few mild
framerate issues that sometimes take the
edge off it's more dramatic moments GTA
5 is the bar by which all other
open-world games or indeed any game that
aims for a cinematic feel should be
judged it is beautiful
thought-provoking thrilling and an
incredible adventure from start to
finish even if you played through it
once already it's worth going back just
to be reminded of what an achievement
this game truly is
[Music]
[Music]